Спекотній літній день.
Поки одні втамовують спрагу прохолодними напоями,
ховаючись у затінку, 18-річна Тетяна з неморською засмагою працює в поті чола.
Вона запрошує киян та гостей столиці покататися з вітерцем на катері.
Її робочий день навіть у вихідні триває понад 12 годин.
Тим не менше, каже, попри такий щільний графік
голосування на позачергових парламентських виборах не пропустить.
Від нового парламенту вона очікує в першу чергу закінченя війни.
Ну, не знаю! Я б напевне хотіла, щоб закінчилась війна,
оскільки мій тато військовий, для нього теж важко втрачати своїх курсантів, близьких людей, синів.
25-річний одесит Льоня міг би зараз пити прохолодне вино десь на набережній Тель-Авіва.
Саме туди, каже, емігрували майже всі його друзі.
Натомість смакує сидр з дині на березі Дніпра в Києві
і думає про те, як самому долучитися до змін у країні.
Я збираюся не тільки йти на ці вибори, але й іти балотуватися на місцеві вибори наступного року.
Бо мені не байдуже, що буде з моїм рідним містом.
Спершу здається, що це просто портрети.
Та придивившись, розумієш, що всі картини об’єднує спільна деталь - дрони.
Для української молоді це не просто іграшки.
Дрони асоціюються також з війною, ділиться враженнями від виставки майбутній політичний аналітик,
а поки 22-річний студент Денис.
Так само пильно він дивиться і на українську політику.
Мріє, щоб за рахунок голосів таких, як він, Верховна Рада нарешті по-справжньому оновилася.
Я все ж таки втомився від старої еліти, яка була присутньою з того часу.
Я вважаю, що потрібні нові люди, ті,
які не будуть приходити в Верховну Раду і займатися кнопкодавством.
Таня не надто охоче читає політичні програми партій.
Нині переймається іншим: за місяць - весілля.
Потрібні гроші. На минулих виборах їй пропонували заробити, попрацювавши в штабі одного з політиків.
І хоча сама вона кандидата не підтримувала, втім, за 1000 гривень на день була готова агітувати за нього.
Для дівчини це чималі гроші.
Я думаю, що кожна людина в Україні, кому не вистачає грошей, погодилася б продати свій голос.
Ні за які гроші та обіцянки Денис свій голос не продасть.
Я б не продав свій голос, я не можу.
Від нової Ради Денис очікує насамперед змін в освіті.
Хлопець проти того, щоб українську землю продавали іноземцям.
І зі здивуванням дізнається, що партія, за яку збирається голосувати,
виступає за вільний продаж землі.
Ще такої чіткої реформи у них немає, хотілося б, звичайно...
Я ж не можу просити у них щось... в когось там щось добре, в інших там...
Якщо не складеться з політичною кар'єрою - відкриє власне кафе, мріє Леонід.
Він очікує, що у найближчі 5 років нові обличчя в Раді
активно боротимуться з корупцією та ухвалять закони, які полегшать ведення бізнесу.
Не те, що підходить до тебе пожежна та каже: ми зачиняємо твій бізнес, бо тут драбина металева.
Я, може, погано на цьому розуміюся, я ще молодий і не вивчав цього.
Я, можливо, кажу загальними фразами.
Але держава має допомагати вести бізнес, а не заважати цьому.
На новому популярному туристичному маршруті Києва -
у народі на мосту Кличка - 24-річна сумчанка Саша не вперше.
Втім, пройтися по скляному фрагменту моста їй знову не вдалося. Тут досі стоїть огорожа.
Дівчина, яка працює в міжнародній фірмі і займається верифікацією мікросхем,
обурюється халатністю будівельників. За таку ж непрофесійність сварить і сучасних політиків.
Тому що зараз ми бачимо, що вибори виграють люди, які ведуть блоги, а не пишуть програми.
Всі змінюють команди, і ти навіть не знаєш, за кого голосуєш, коли ти голосуєш за партію.
Саша ретельно вивчає партійні програми.
Їй важливо віддати голос за тих, хто продовжить медичну реформу Уляни Супрун
та впроваджуватиме електронний документообіг.
Бо електронна система не дає можливості якось її підкупити.
Електроніка працює так, як її налаштували.
Я сподіваюсь, що займуться освітою, бо як людина, яка рік тому захистила магістерську дисертацію,
я знаю, які проблеми в освіті.
Я бачила наш Національний технічний університет зсередини, і це жахливо.
Там дуже обрані люди, через яких ти хочеш тягнутися до науки.
Молоді люди, яких DW випадково зустріла на вулицях Києва, виявилися політично активними.
Усі збираються йти на вибори, щоб віддати свій голос за нові обличчя у владі.
Їм імпонує те, що нові партії, та й низка старих,
використовують сучасні методи комунікації, як-от Instagram чи Facebook.
Утім, за легким піаром у соцмережах все-таки хотіли би бачити реальні політичні програми.